[Music]
in circle of life news in the circle
submitted by Joe Malian executioner
that's that's me nokey there he's Papa's
they're probably like your minions you
think it uh they do the ground you're
the minister of torture files wanna be
the guy that goes but now you have an
option because you have that guy like
sometimes higher up he'll oceans up your
arms before you he's massage then cuz
you've got a couple hundred heads that
day that's a lot of parties number one
yeah by biceps or dry he's been a
controversial a controversial class has
students hatching and raising chickens
before eating them that's really cool
don't why is that contrary all I'm
tripping out that they were eating the
baby chicks okay you can t be chicks do
a balloon that's balloon no those are
dogs do [ __ ] ducks but seriously though
III don't know how I would feel about
that to be honest cuz like I mean I
guess it can teaches you like the value
of life and [ __ ] and the value of your
food that's true dad we do the same
thing on kindergarten I have you guys
done this where like you plant tomatoes
or carrots or whatever and then they
grow up and then and you eat them
yeah so that we like at the end of the
year I would take my carrots and
radishes home and I would eat them dry
so I'm telling you drags Jack and I'll
eat my [ __ ] produce that's the same
[ __ ] as this grew up like in a rural
farm area and she was like we didn't
need that much meat because we had to do
all of the work so like they had
chickens in the back and stuff but it
was an occasional thing cuz they had to
clean kill all that stuff there's a lot
of smoker that's why they said like in
like in general like if people wanted to
lose weight if you think about food and
how you're supposed to process it
yourself you'll already lose weight so
like if you want to get tired thinking
about it yeah
like this if you want a hamburger right
it's like cool you ain't much hamburgers
as you want but you got to go kill the
cow you got to do if you did that then
you think about it oh I wouldn't eat a
hamburger every day that's something I
would have every now they're gonna raise
a cow first exactly so that's if like if
you think of food like that then people
start to like lose weight super fast
unless yeah I'm not yeah I like
hamburgers when I wanted to skim my
hamburger dog but I like that it kind of
teaches you like the value of just like
appreciating that that that life-form
yeah ever since I saw avatar when when
he whenever the tribe would like kill an
animal or something they would be like
they would like the bit like thank you
they would say like oh thank you for
this meal or whatever you know I was
like oh okay that's dope that kind of
makes me like appreciate a little more
that's why I feel like when I eat weird
[ __ ] I feel like it gives me life energy
you know yeah I feel that way a little
bit like when I like I eat like a piece
of steak I get the energy of the steak
yeah yeah yeah yeah I get that didn't I
eat like a pig this is a Native American
philosophy yeah yeah I don't know first
- if you watch naked and afraid you'd
understand it straight up there's this
episode this is episode this guy he's
like this former military dude right
marine guy and this other girl she's all
about respecting life and there was this
electric eel in the Amazon he stabs that
[ __ ] in the head right he goes hello
mr. eel I don't like that you disrespect
the animal he goes oh I'm sorry no but
then he ends up apologizing yes he does
he cries he goes yeah he starts bawling
in front of her that come from a place
war you know you don't really think
about it was great he stabbed he
literally like yeah when you're hungry
you got crazy yeah so this class here
for the past 60 years
every generation of freshman students at
this particular high school in Japan has
60 years has taken the class of life
which is a fixed month course where
students help hatch and raise chickens
and then slaughtering them and then
eating them I
we have to eat the chicken like siren
but you don't have to do you want you to
pass the class oh my god and they all
have their own chicken their own - the
funny thing is this is this is normal
like human [ __ ] yeah we're supposed to
be doing right we used to have chickens
in our backyard we used to have this
[ __ ] and everyone had to do it but now
we're so disconnected with our food it's
like that were actually appalled
mortified we're like oh my god
actually this is don't talk though if
you're a Mexican or Hmong they do this
on a break in the dude Hmong people
always got chicken in their backyard in
Sacramento I'm Mexican I've never
experienced it once
oh yeah rooster yeah rooster before yeah
we didn't kill it and eat it yeah how do
you know well yeah where's yeah now huh
what do you know cuz you told me you
didn't grow up on pork on pork and your
mom said she made pork like every other
night do you even know where it is
something wrong with me because when
we're in when we're in Hawaii and I see
those chickens running around I want to
kill it pluck it and make soup or
something I saw that they have a class
here in LA that do that but they
actually teach you how to catch and
prepare kale and prepared yeah I mean
I'll take a dead the other yeah do it
from scratch I don't have to kill it
even just a raw hold chicken like I
would remember I was helping Casey's mom
prepared some food for a dinner for
Christmas and she had me like cleaning
this dead chicken and I'm just like
every time I have to crack a bone and
like peel up I was just like carcass but
I still want to try to do that class
though just like get over it and
appreciate my food because I definitely
chicken have feathers on it no I did it
I love the smell of dead chicken chicken
it fish I could give a [ __ ] less about
but then like sometimes like I'll see a
cow tell them what kind of cute dude I
think I could give a [ __ ] less about
anything
this might sound crazy no this might
sound crazy but in a different society
in a different world if I had to [ __ ]
animal I got things the same thing -
okay that went left real quick in a
different society yet people accept that
here
I mean want me to go off of what you
were saying - yeah but sometimes because
like their cue but they could look
delicious because they got some long
eyelashes like Sacramento - it's like
paying attention you're a pervert it
sends a pervert they'll have like an
Aggie day or whatever right I forgot
what the [ __ ] it was called but they
bring like a baby calf in right and it's
just looking at you with this big ol
eyes and it wants to be pet and [ __ ] and
it gets all excited so ever since then I
haven't eaten veal really yeah so I just
eat regular cows now when they grow up
to be legs look like fat humans which
are adorable if you look at the eyes of
a pig as human I know into a [ __ ]
human oh god that's why they taste so
bad okay how is the [ __ ] though pulling
the pigs looking at Piggy and I [ __ ]
huh you know whose eyes are weird
[ __ ] goat eyes you go swearing goats
got the demon eyes weird you know what's
the cutest guys in the world
Tyco Oh cute no donkeys dude there's
like this one eyes are so big enough you
taking a picture of a donkey when
they're like bit making a face it's
disgusting right like that jaws here to
here oh yeah we met I love donkeys yeah
their teeth all [ __ ] up in [ __ ] is
this like a rural area in Japan like a
farm Japan do you know where it is
no sounds like some bum [ __ ] you mean
she mean Perfector Shimane prefecture
prefecture thank you I feel like every
major city should have this because I
feel like the more rural the area of my
New York Los Angeles Beijing Tokyo
London like they got a half [ __ ] like
this I feel like the more city someone
is the less human they are yeah they're
disconnected with each other
relationships family all they do is like
[ __ ] work make a ton of money buy a
lot of [ __ ] but like lonely as [ __ ] yeah
after them but then I feel like people
in small towns or like you know farm
areas or whatever they're more connected
but they dream of coming to the city
it's like I don't know man cross is a
good point but but [ __ ] dad I must stay
my house in the city I'm like I love
Sacramento but sometimes like because I
got so used to having everything so
accessible in such a small area like
it's hard to sacraments you had to
travel far to go to places and so like
I'm sitting there just like can I like
move I can't move back but I would miss
the fact that I could just go 1/4 mile
here and then I get everything I need
mm-hmm you know and I like that no one
really knows me you know what I mean
like Oh in more rural small town
everyone [ __ ] knows [ __ ] you know
what I mean like but then in the city
it's like man
take good care less everyone's too busy
everyone kind of goes to like one like
laundromat and one line yeah yeah yeah
so everyone knows each other yeah I'm in
the big city like crazy yeah you don't
you kind of shielded from that [ __ ] and
probably like any girl you try to talk
to has already like [ __ ] your homey in
the past too
you know what feels like that like for
us in the city HOA
oh really really okay the community's
yet it feels like that I don't talk to
nobody film they're probably talking
about you though what are the HOA
meeting I do not see you know you're
[ __ ] up we found out we're [ __ ] up
wait really
yeah so they they were picking on us
because we had a gemini garage and I'm
like what the [ __ ] like there's like at
least four other houses that have a
weight set they just call ours a gym cuz
I have a decal on the wall okay no it's
not going to my real estate agent he
goes oh you're not playing the game
because what you got to do is you got to
go to the HOA meetings right exactly
yeah bring some cookies cupcakes talk it
and I like smooth things over and then
you become one of the favorites and
that's how those guys they get there are
the ones that are able to break the
rules and do it over the hell they want
but for us on my nash it's lame I don't
know that [ __ ] yeah that's why I like
ghetto me just talk to everyone when you
get murdered nobody acts like they know
[ __ ] yeah when your neighbors have
chickens it's all good hey their rooster
gets loose and the other pit bull comes
out and bites them it don't matter
cuz even for me like back at homes who
like our neighbors have hella pit bulls
and they're [ __ ] loud I'm just like
that's annoying
whatever yeah man be a [ __ ] whatever
like you know they'll wake me up every
now and then they call the cops on our
dogs barking inside the house really
like they're inside the house already
and if they're loud and you can hear
them it's I don't know it's the design
of the house it's not us the price you
paid for safety man dad I know they have
been a gated community I know I missed
the mariachi music hall like at 3:00
a.m. and then or it's either that a
Filipino Vietnamese family singing
karaoke at 2:00 a.m. on my street in
Sacramento every [ __ ] Sunday the last
house at the end
mariachi music every Sunday yeah they
have up and if you walk by they invite
you here the buggy somebody else you
Bands Braga's e-every know they they
always have [ __ ] hell a family there
I mean they always invite everybody that
just means that's their family that's
just messaging that's [ __ ] great but
every Sunday since I was a kid they've
been doing it all the [ __ ] time and
it's like I got accustomed to it I kind
of enjoy it yeah it's so festive and if
they don't have it it's like yo somebody
that that's a Mexican family do it's
always very festive [ __ ] dope we have
birthdays we have [ __ ] about these
malls we have quinceañeras what's about
be small
autism Oh every single demonics used to
get together because we even do that the
the other little strap yeah I'm in
February we just think what's a lot
roscas gonna thread with it's like a
baby Jesus how did you get with the East
Asian that's like the total opposite you
know who else is like that to African
people Afghan no African they want a
drinking party at any type of occasion
they want so it's like is somebody just
happy people second grade third grade
it's like adult hey when you say African
well what part of Africa are you well
from what I know is this all of those
Rwandan mmm so like they try that like
any kind of occasion they're getting
everybody together so as always though
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]